Maintaining flow is similar
to catching a current in the ocean.
Once you're in it, you seem to be
gliding with the flow rather than
almost trying to hold on to it.
It's something that just comes to you
and you stay with it.
Flow is when a person is in
a highly focussed mental state
where nothing else seems to matter.
It occurs when
your perceived skill level
and the challenge at hand are equal,
and you are as in control of your
mind and body as you can be.
When I experience flow I just feel
really, really focussed
and everything seems to works for me.
You just feel confident
in everything you do
there's no negative
thoughts coming in
so you just feel like you can perform
to your best each time.
The key aspects of flow
are being able to perform a task
seemingly automatically,
having absolute concentration
on the task at hand,
maintaining a sense of control
over the performance
and a loss of self-consciousness.
In tennis there can be tons of things
that can distract you.
When it comes to sport, many athletes
focus on the outcome of the game
the match or the race,
the desire to win,
or they become distracted
by how they played in the last point.
When athletes dwell on these
egocentric thoughts
we'll often see them
start to lose focus
and their performance
starts to deteriorate.
The most difficult thing
about staying in flow
is the external things.
Your opponent is obviously... Can be
one of the most distracting things,
and just to isolate yourself
sometimes from your opponent
and simply focus on what you're doing
really helps for more focus
and flow display.
Although being in a state of flow is
something that's usually associated
with high level athletes,
it's something that potentially
anyone is able to achieve.
From playing an instrument
to a surgeon carrying out
a complex operation.
But what can you do to give yourself
the best possible chance
for achieving a state of flow?
Here are my tips to help increase
the probability of flow
in your everyday life.
Sports psychologist Bob Rotella
highlighted the importance of letting
go of memories of shots, good or bad,
and focus on the here and now,
as it really helps you focus
on the process
and what you're specifically doing
at that moment in time.
This could be achieved through
setting mastery orientated goals,
and you can recite to yourself
at times throughout the performance.
A key characteristic of flow
is immediate feedback.
This can be provided by teammates,
coaches or yourself
as you complete the activity.
When possible, try to figure out
what you're doing well and why.
As well as what you can
be doing better and how.
This will make you an active learner
and aid the development
of future goals and targets
necessary to achieve
your desired outcome.
Be a better practitioner
of your skills, not a goal chaser.
This feedback can be based on your
pre-set mastery orientated goals.
Am I achieving these or not?
What can I do to achieve these?
Doing this as quickly as possible
will help you effectively move
on from situations,
and focus on the present.
If the task is too easy then focus
is extremely difficult to achieve
and it may become tedious.
If the task is too difficult
you may feel anxious about whether
or not you can meet the demands.
Make sure you always set yourself
goals that match your skill level,
but also challenge you.
When you achieve these goals,
set yourself more challenging
targets in order to remain in flow.
I personally find flow quite easy
to remain in but hard to find.
But once you find it,
you're in the zone
an d, as it says, you just
flow through the match.
Thanks for watching! :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!